AROUND.
JOINING ME NOW IS A MAN WHO I
BELIEVE AGREES WITH THAT
SENTIMENT, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN FROM CALIFORNIA
DEVIN NUNES.
CONGRESSMAN, I THINK I HAVE LAID
OUT THE NATURE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, REGARDLESS
EVEN OF THE DETAILS.
THE FACT IS ONCE AGAIN IT'S LIKE
A MONSTER TRUCK MOVING THROUGH.
WHAT IS YOUR EXPERIENCE ON THE
CAPITOL RIGHT NOW AND WHY DID 17
REPUBLICANS VOTE WITH THE
DEMOCRATS TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN?
>> WELL, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
WASHINGTON THIS DYSFUNCTIONAL
AND I HAVE BEEN HERE A WHILE AND
I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
DYSFUNCTION.
BUT, PELOSI HAS MANAGED TO
COMPLETELY BURN DOWN THIS
INSTITUTION.
I KNOW YOU COVERED THE MASKS AND
CDC AND ALL THE GAMES.
BUT THEY HAVE WEAPONIZED AND
DESTROYED EVERYTHING HERE.
SO, LOOK, THIS BILL, WE
HAVEN'T -- THE EARLY INDICATIONS
OF THIS BILL IS THAT IT IS NOT
EVEN PAID FOR.
SO, HERE'S WHAT THE POLITICIANS
KEEP DOING HERE IN WASHINGTON IS
THEY DON'T WANT TO MAKE THE
TOUGH DECISIONS.
SO IF YOU REALLY WANT TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE, THAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE GAS TAX
THAT EVERYONE PAYS AT THE PUMP.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO NATURALLY NO ONE WANTS TO
GO INCREASE GAS PRICES AT THE
PUMP.
AND WHAT WE ARE NOT DOING.
LOOK, EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT WE
NEED INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE CONSTANTLY NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT NOBODY IS ASKING THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS WHY ARE STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
TAXES AND THE HIGHEST GAS PRICES
IN THE COUNTRY OUR ROADS ARE THE
VERY WORST ROADS.
AND I HAVE BEEN IN MANY OTHER
STATES, TRAVELING AROUND THE
COUNTRY, RECRUITING CANDIDATES
AND TRYING TO GET THE MESSAGE
OUT ABOUT THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
IN CALIFORNIA HOW WE DON'T WANT
TO BRING THEM TO WASHINGTON, AND
THE THING THAT I FIND, TAMMY, IS
THAT IT'S REALLY HARD TO FIGURE
OUT, WHY ARE ROADS SO MUCH
BETTER IN OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
SUCH LOWER GAS PRICES?
IT'S REALLY HARD TO BELIEVE.
SO, THIS LOOKS REALLY GIMMICKY.
I KNOW SOME OF THOSE SENATORS.
SO I'M NOT SURE I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR THOUGHT PROCESS
ON THIS.
BUT, AT THIS POINT IN TIME, WHEN
THEY ARE CLAIMING THAT THIS BILL
IS PAID FOR, WE DON'T SEE IT
THAT WAY.
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS LOOKED
AT IT WE THINK THIS IS A LOT OF
MOVING AND SHELL GAMES OF MONEY
AROUND.
>> Tammy: BUT THAT'S NOT
UNUSUAL.
AMERICANS WATCH THIS, WE KEEP
WATCHING IT THE OBAMACARE BILL
YOU HAVE GOT TO SIGN IT BEFORE
YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN IT.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
AND, THERE IS GENERAL CASH, WE
WOULD HOPE AND THIS IS WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS.
MANY ARGUE WITH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THAT IT'S MORE OF THE SAME.
THAT THERE IS REALLY NO REAL --
EACH IDEOLOGICAL DIVISION THAT
THIS IS ABOUT MONEY FOR THE
MOBSTER OF GOVERNMENT UNIPARTY.
ACTIONS LIKE THIS MOVE THROUGH
PAST THIS CLOTURE I DO MA'AM NIC
SOMETHING THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
IN IT LET ALONE HOW IT'S GOING
TO BE PAID FOR.
CONSIDERING THE MONEY NOW THAT
IS MOVING THROUGH.
THEN THIS OTHER BILL THE
$3 TRILLION ONE THAT SANDERS
TALKS ABOUT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THAT?
IS THAT GOING TO BE MOVED ON
THROUGH AS WELL?
>> WELL, THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO
SAY NEXT.
SO, NOT ONLY IS THIS BILL NOT
PAID FOR.
BUT PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT PELOSI HAS BEEN OVER HERE
SAYING AS HAVE OTHER
PROGRESSIVES THAT THIS BILL GOES
NOWHERE UNLESS THEY PASS THE
$3.5 TRILLION BILL, WHICH IS
REALLY THE HOLY GRAIL OF WHAT
THE COUNTRY WANTS IN THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE THEN THEY GET
PASSED.
THEY DON'T NEED CLOTURE OR THE
60 VOTES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET 50 VOTES
OVER THERE IN THE SENATE.
THEY WANT THE 50 VOTES, HAVE THE
VICE PRESIDENT COME OVER AND
BREAK THE TIE.
SEND IT OVER HERE AND PUSH IT
THROUGH.
AND THEY CAN SPEND THE NEXT YEAR
TRYING TO DO TREMENDOUS DAMAGE
TO THIS COUNTRY.
SO I JUST HOPE THAT MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE AREN'T CREATING A
VEHICLE, A POLITICAL VEHICLE SO
TO SPEAK THAT ALLOWS THIS TO
BE -- THE SKIDS TO BE GREASED.
THAT'S WHAT PELOSI AND THE
PROGRESSIVES ARE SAYING.
AND, LOOK, MOST OF THE TIME WHEN
THEY MAKE THESE THREATS, THEY GO
EVEN FARTHER LEFT THAN WHAT THEY
ARE INDICATING THEY ARE GOING TO
GO.
>> Tammy: I DON'T THINK YOU WERE
TOLD, WARNED ABOUT THIS
QUESTION.
I WANT TO SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO SAY ABOUT SOME OF
THE REPORTS THAT THERE IS A
REQUEST BY, I THINK, BY THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS TO REMOVE
KINZINGER AND CHENEY FROM THE
CAUCUS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
CONSIDERING THEIR PARTICIPATION
IN THE JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE AND
THAT, OF COURSE, A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE UP IN ARMS ABOUT THEIR
ATTITUDE.
>> LOOK, I HAVE HAD A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE WITH THE SCAM ON THAT
COMMITTEE AND WHAT PELOSI PUT
TOGETHER AND THE PEOPLE THAT SHE
PUT ON THAT COMMITTEE.
THE CHALLENGE IS AND THIS -- I
HAVE TALKED TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS IS THAT PELOSI
HAS TAKEN UNPRECEDENTED STEP OF
PUTTING PEOPLE WHEREVER SHE
WANTS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY WHERE YOU HAVE THE
MAJORITY PARTY, THE SPEAKER
DECIDING WHO GETS PUT ON TO
PARTIES.
SO,.
>> Tammy: THEY COULD SAY NO.
CHENEY AND KINZINGER COULD HAVE
SAID NO AND THEY DIDN'T SO IS
THE G.O.P. GOING TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THEM?
>> WELL, THEY SHOULD HAVE SAID
NO.
BUT HERE'S THE ISSUE.
IF WE -- US KICKING THEM OFF THE
COMMITTEE MAKES NO DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE SHE JUST PUTS THEM BACK
ON.
SO THAT'S THE ISSUE HERE.
AND, LOOK, AND SHE CAN GO EACH
FARTHER THAN THAT WE ARE IN
UNCHATTERRED TERRITORY SPEAKER
DECIDING WHERE REPUBLICANS SIT
ON COMMITTEES.
>> Tammy: I AGREE.
ALL OF IT IS AWFUL YET THERE IS
A QUESTION ABOUT WHAT IS THE
G.O.P. EVER GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR YOU,
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON BUT THOSE QUESTIONS WILL
CONTINUE.
>> TAMMY, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THE VOTERS IN THOSE STATES WILL
HAVE TO SPEAK.
AND THAT'S COMING QUICKLY.
>> Tammy: WE'RE NOT AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE ARE RIGHT HERE